hello and welcome back to rollercoaster
code three one of the main things that I
wanted to get done in this episode which
I should have done a very very long time
ago but I still didn't because I didn't
download it is to use new textures as
you may be able to see as you probably
am seeing is that I've got some
different textures in the game which are
from DK ethanol spice I think that's
them and it's very similar to what Old
Spice has released about a year ago
maybe it's even two years ago honestly
where he actually changed some of the
textures in game however we contrary to
that earlier different set of textures
you don't have to reload a certain mod
program every time that you get these
textures you just download these
textures and you replace the in-game
text to your files with these and you
get these shiny new textures I myself
I'm actually not too sure whether I like
these textures more than the in-game
ones one of the main issues that I have
with them is that the grass is very dark
especially the grass that you get as a
sort of template standard grants that
you start off with in your pike so I
like to just recolor everything to a
lighter shade of grass but that said you
can kind of just find your way around
things and especially when it comes to
these more rocky textures or the path
textures they are much better than
what's in game and especially the brick
paving sort of texture turned out to be
very useful for the English areas as
well as some other areas in the park and
I'm really happy with it overall and it
didn't even take too much time to redo
all the textures but yeah I did have to
kind of go over the park again and
replace all the textures with these new
ones because they did sort of swap some
textures around I think there are less
grass textures in this pack as there are
in the original game so sometimes if you
move over to these new textures your
fields of grass and the turn into fields
of rocky [ __ ] and you kind of just
have to repaint some things but it's
been really not that bad over all the
other things that I wanted to do in this
episode was get some more detail onto
this log flume because it was still
looking very boring one of the main
issues that I have with this one is that
although I do like the theme overall and
it does look pretty good I had to keep
it all at one level like there is the
water level and I couldn't really go
higher or lower than that but in the end
it kind of resulted in a very big lake
which sort of makes the area look very
empty and boring so really the only
remedy I figured I would have against
that is just filthy like with details
and pretty things to look at until it
doesn't look so boring and empty anymore
and that's one thing that I wanted to do
and I also kind of wanted to finish the
palettes around the English area which
I'll get to later and actually whoa that
was perfect timing
I got two right now and there's also
some other stuff like making this area
look a little bit less gray I know that
I've commented way too many times that
sort of my excuse for keeping this area
so great brownish and dull looking and
almost depressing is that it is England
in the end so it probably shouldn't be
too big of an issue but then again I
can't get away with this are you looking
this depressing it is a theme park after
all so one of my main remedies to sort
of make this area look less depressing
is at some foliage not just little trees
but also little flowers and things like
that
maybe I'll get two signs and banners
later on still not too sure about that
but the first thing that I wanted to do
is finish this palace I don't even know
why I didn't do that earlier because you
can kind of see me struggling here these
different little borders and cornices
are made up with different customs in
resets but I always tend to forget what
because some scenery sets are used for
certain pieces so it's always a bit of a
puzzle to find those sets again through
all of the hundreds of sets that I have
and figure out exactly where I need to
use which pieces so my word of advice is
basically if you're working on a
building and you might not finish it in
time just do it in one session because
if you don't and you the next section
the next session is in a very long time
after your first session you tend to
forget what sort of pieces you've used
or at least I do
it also kind of depends on what sort of
thing you're building obviously this
palace is something that I haven't
really done before too much so something
that I had to get used to of what sort
of pieces I'm using whereas if you're
using al pine theme or something like
that it's just spam shyguys alpine
village and go from there
so in that it kind of depends but
usually I would say try to finish your
buildings in one session it's it usually
results in the best things now this case
it doesn't really matter too much since
it's just a simple wing of the building
really but still it really helps to
finish things in one one go it's it's
almost it's it's also kind of more fun I
usually feel like if I still have to
finish a building it's it's more like a
chore I need to finish this building
still whereas if I have a nice girl
building a building and making it look
like I want to it always it always is
more of a nice sitting to me really and
then there's a bit of foliage because I
didn't know what to help other like I
didn't even know what else to do at this
point I just figured the next thing that
I have to do or at least the next two
things that I have to do is after this
finish up the sort of transition area to
the I think it's gonna be the German
area that I'll be next to this I'm
pretty damn sure which I am not too sure
how I'm gonna do it whether I want to
cover it with buildings all the way or
just have a couple of small buildings
around it or more foliage so I still
kind of want to figure that out and I
don't want to start building it yet
until I figured out what I want to do
with it and the other thing is the dark
right but I am really not I'm not
prepared for that yet so that's
something I gonna want to do later on as
well but other than that I just kind of
wandered around the park adding little
details here and there some subtle
changes to I wanted I wanted to have
some more vertical action in this
building especially since when you look
at real Victorian buildings especially
the palace what is it called actually
the the building with which has the long
journey attached to it I I feel so very
awkward for forgetting the name of that
thing in any case the
it's when a ministry of England is that
building in London like the most famous
building in the world almost anyway that
type of building usually it has lots of
vertical stuff going on with all sorts
of pillars and towers and this building
didn't really have it enough yet so I
figured I could add more of those little
small details here and there and also
skim through some sets to find some
dormers which turned out to be an almost
impossible sort of thing to do so in the
end I just had to go with some really
small boring looking dormers that you
can barely see it's better than nothing
I suppose but dormers is something that
I always have trouble with finding
especially since so many of the custom
scenery sets that you do have usually
you have a lot of leeway in what you
know you make with walls and roofs since
you can combine the walls of one set
with the roofs another set and get the
details of another set into that but
when it comes to dormers that usually
the complete package the the wall the
window and the roof altogether and that
kind of makes it really hard to find the
right dormers in all the custom scenery
sets that you have if the rest of the
building is one big mash-up of different
sets to create its own unique atmosphere
in any case I always have a lot of
trouble finding the right dormers and in
the end just go with the mediocre ones
that kind of do the job at least but
aren't really a 100% what I was trying
to go for and over here I figured you
know this is I'm not gonna build the dog
ride in this park since the park
definitely can't take it but I at least
should have some sort of little thing
over here that could look like it's the
entrance of the queue to this dark ride
which is what that little red carpet
over there should be actually tried to
make it a carpets using this carpet set
but it didn't quite cover the path cover
pieces that I had over there so that
kind of sucked but it's supposed to look
like a red carpet I think it still kind
of makes it look like it's actually a
red carpet for whatever reason it just
looks cool and that should be the cue to
the dark ride which should be finished
in a different sandbox eventually I'm
also very much afraid that the dark ride
is gonna take very long so I'm actually
gonna keep it sure
I don't even aspire to make it look
anything like a mystic machine or
imaginary own stuff which if you're into
dark rides and you haven't seen mystic
machine or anything that imagine a John
has made you need to check that stuff
out because it's really good but I don't
even think I can live up to that and I
don't even have the time to live up to
that for one attraction in an entire
park so this dog ride will just be
pretty small and simple just kind of I
need to learn the ropes still anyway so
it won't really be too much but it's
still quite a big hurdle for me to step
over in this let's play park and he'll
probably take quite some episodes to do
actually also sort of wondering how it
all turned out since it's something that
I've never ever done but it's also
something that I've never ever made
videos of so I'm not quite sure how good
a footage is gonna be for the let's play
but seemingly some people are looking
forward to it and think it would be cool
so I guess I'll do that and the last
thing that I sort of did over here was
at water lilies which is unrealistic as
[ __ ] you don't have water lilies you
know like the thing with water lilies is
you either have them a little bit here
in their clustered or you have them
everywhere but here it's sort of
in-between and there's a log flume as
well which doesn't really happen but I
figured
bummer head looks cool so let's have it
anyway but yeah that's it for this
episode so thank you for watching and
I'll see you guys in the next episode
and which I have no idea what I'm gonna
do
so anyways see you then